So what if the real power of
firearms in America has almost
nothing to do with when they're
fired, but everything to do with
when they're not?
Today we're diving into a really
fascinating framework from
writer Chris Abraham.
He argues that private firearms
in the US act less like weapons
and more like a form of stored
potential energy, something he
calls sequestered carbon.
It all starts with a number, a
really, really big 1/2 a
billion.
That's the estimated number of
privately owned firearms in
America today.
Now, a number that massive,
well, it naturally leads to a
pretty profound question.
And there it is.
If the overwhelming majority of
these half a billion firearms
are never actually used in a
crime or a conflict, what are
they even for?
The argument we're going to
unpack here is that their true
power, their real function, lies
in their potential, in their
silence.
And this brings us to the
central metaphor of the whole
idea, sequestered carbon.
Just think of it like a massive
underground reserve of fuel.
It has a huge impact on the
world just by existing, right?
The point isn't to burn it.
All its power comes from the
fact that it could be used.
So let's see how this applies to
the structure of power in a
society.
OK, so to really get what
sequestered carbon means in this
context, we've got a first
breakdown, how the author views
the architecture of power in any
given nation.
So according to the source
material, most countries around
the world run on three basic
layers of power.
You've got your official
governance, you know, city
councils, police, the stuff you
see on the news.
Then you've got the shadow
authority, the gangs, the
cartels, the networks that
operate outside the law but
still hold real power.
And finally, you have the
federal level, the national
government, the military, the
big guns that can step in.
But, and this is the absolute
core of the argument, the United
States has a unique fourth
layer.
This layer is made-up of those
500 million privately owned
firearms.
It's not organized, it's totally
dispersed, but it acts as a
permanent structural
counterweight to the other
three.
And this really gets to the
philosophical why of it all.
This fourth layer isn't about
planning some kind of uprising
according to this framework.
It's a constitutional feature
that's meant to be a constant
silent reminder that all power
depends on the consent of the
governed, and that consent can
be taken back.
So let's drill down on the
constitutional function of this
fourth layer.
The argument here is that its
main purpose isn't for things
like hunting or sports shooting,
but for something far more
fundamental to the structure of
the nation itself.
And here's where you see the big
contrast.
You know, a lot of the public
conversation revolves around
hunting, sport and collecting.
But this constitutional argument
bypasses all of that.
It centers on this idea of
parity, the idea that the
citizenry should maintain a
level of armament that could, in
theory, act as a credible check
on a standing army, and by doing
so, deter any attempts at
tyranny before they even start.
Now you might be thinking, come
on, a muzzle loader from 1791 is
nothing like a modern rifle.
And you're right.
But according to the author,
that's exactly the point.
The principle of parody isn't
frozen in time.
It means protecting access to
the kinds of arms that are
contemporary to the era.
The technology evolves, but the
purpose, that core idea of a
check on power, remains the
same.
And look, this isn't just some
fringe theory floating out
there.
The author points out that
recent court decisions have
actually reinforced this view of
the Second Amendment.
And what's driving it isn't just
one single powerful lobby.
It's a broad grass roots demand
for ownership, with newer, more
aggressive advocacy groups also
playing a big role.
OK, so this brings us to the
biggest, most obvious challenge
to this whole theory.
And it's a real paradox, one
that's all about the nature of
deterrence itself.
So the critics step in and say,
wait a minute, If these half a
billion guns are supposed to be
a deterrent against tyranny, but
they're never actually used for
that, doesn't that just prove
the whole deterrent thing is a
myth?
And you know what?
It's a really good logical
question.
And here is the author's
rebuttal, which really gets to
the heart of that sequestered
carbon idea.
A deterrent that has to be used
has already failed.
The entire point of a deterrent
is that it works by not being
used.
Its success is measured by its
silence.
It's a little abstract, I know.
So think of it like this.
The world's nuclear arsenals
keep a certain kind of peace
precisely because they are not
launched.
Or think about a fire
extinguisher in your kitchen.
It's value isn't 0 just because
your house hasn't burned down.
It's value is there every single
day a fire doesn't happen.
It's all about the potential
held in reserve.
Now this doesn't mean it's a
complete free for all.
The author is very clear that
this fourth layer has to be self
policing.
If someone in this layer misuses
their arms, commits a crime,
threatens people and the other
layers, the police and the
federal government come crashing
down on them.
So it's legitimacy really
depends on responsible,
restrained ownership.
So if this fourth layer is a
real thing, who's in it?
And more importantly, is that
changing?
Well, according to this
analysis, it's expanding in ways
that might surprise you.
What we're seeing, according to
the source, is a major
realignment.
Groups that have not
traditionally been associated
with gun ownership are now
arming themselves and in doing
so, participating In this fourth
layer.
We're talking about LGBTQ
activists, leftist organizers,
minority communities, and
various progressive coalitions.
And here's the kicker.
The reaction from traditional,
long standing Second Amendment
advocates isn't horror or fear.
According to the author, it's
often welcome.
The thinking is that the
constitutional principle is
actually made stronger when a
more diverse range of citizens
embraces it for their own self
preservation.
And this totally reframes the
tension.
It's no longer about identity.
You know who looks like a gun
owner?
The central question becomes a
commitment to the principle
itself.
It becomes, OK, you've armed
yourself for your own
protection, I get that.
But will you defend my right to
do the same, even if we disagree
on everything else politically?
So what's the ultimate take away
from this whole framework?
It's that this fourth layer of
private arms doesn't rule or
govern.
It doesn't dictate terms.
It's real function is to make
sure that no other group can
dictate terms without
negotiation, without consent.
You can almost picture it like
this.
It's not a pyramid with the
fourth layer at the top or
bottom.
It's more like a four way
balance.
This fourth layer just acts as a
structural counterweight,
preventing any one of the other
three from gaining a total
monopoly on force.
And in the end, the simple,
quiet existence of this
sequestered carbon, this massive
reserve of stored potential, is
what enforces a peaceful
process.
Why?
Because it completely eliminates
the fantasy that anyone group
could ever achieve its goals
through unopposed force.
It forces everyone back to the
table and will end on the
author's most provocative line,
which is a real mic drop moment.
It's a challenging thought that
reframes the whole debate,
suggesting that the very
potential for force that people
worry about is exactly what
safeguards the freedom to worry
about it in the first place.
It's a complex idea for sure,
and definitely one worth chewing
on.